do you feel like at times like would you
ever run into any uh
issues when he would take a position on
something oh yeah a ton and you're on
the show with them so do you get
associated with that or are they like yo
fam like what are you doing like yeah
because he was saying some of the
Kaepernick [__] I don't I don't know if
that timeline lines up with speak for
yourself but just some of the things he
was saying about cap and [__] where I
was just like yeah yeah you know it was
just like a little like off-putting I
guess to hear that on like you know I I
I again even like you know
we talk about him leaving and doing his
own thing but hearing that on like ESPN
or Fox at the time it was kind of crazy
some of the things you were saying yeah
and you know without particulars like
um Kaepernick was a hot button issue I
didn't mind that because you know I I
don't even know how you say this
properly but uh I had my issues with
Kaepernick as well but no I think I
think I think as the way you say it well
I think as it kind of the cap thing I
think as it wavered and I it felt like
he really had real opportunities I think
that that Atlanta thing that happened
where he had the workouts yeah and he
wanted to do the workout his way yeah I
was like bro they're giving you the yo I
mean I I
people have come up to me and literally
said can I talk to you for a sec I I'm
sorry I apologize I don't even know
these cats I thought you were sellout I
thought you were against us and all that
and I was like dog I don't even believe
in all that stuff you talking about I
just tell you what I see from my
perspective and my experiences or any
situation I
before all that uh I haven't talked to
him since but I saw the 180 fine you
know I see that ain't the first I guess
for me it was just like the demonization
of someone just kneeling to bring
attention to something obviously you get
into
three or four years later down the road
the lawsuit like he cashed out you know
what I'm saying and then he still had an
opportunity so that's that's the point
though this is the funny I I always tell
people I am not a hater right I just
tell the truth too early and I've said
it wait like day one I'm like I could
read this like it's like if you take me
to a workout and show me some defensive
ends right I need three reps I could
tell you who this and who down here that
fast so I read the situation accurately
um from that moment doesn't mean he's
not doing work but you said it best he
he brought attention but I don't think
the attention was going where everyone
thought it was going a lot of it was
coming back to be self-serving but he's
still doing the work I ain't even mad at
him but I was just like yo this ain't
gonna go like y'all think it's going the
way and the first play he could have had
was challenged the NFL not be
adversarial but challenge the NFL to do
exactly what he wanted but what did he
want he didn't know that's why he didn't
do any q and A's he didn't go out there
didn't do a lot of he's into any
podcasts you mean a lot you mean none
none then also put that money and didn't
say any I mean he I mean we don't know
how much it was right no but I'm sure
the condition of him getting that money
was everything is
yeah if you're the NFL of course you're
going to make them sign the NDA of
course you're going to say you can't go
out there and damage our brand but hey
act like you want to play every single
year yeah and that's that's what you
said it's like if you really really
really wanted to still play I feel like
that that Atlanta thing the way he moved
the workout last minute I was just like
people act like this this at that point
I was like guys okay we got like you a
couple years after me when I was a guy
yeah I know I was I was for sure because
it took me a while but when that
happened
this ain't it what's going on oh you
know what's going on and it's just funny
because I know too many guys that would
die for a workout like I know dudes that
are beasts Ballers right give me a
workout dog that's rap it's on and this
guy had multiple chances and
opportunities and a workout and a
settlement and y'all trying to act like
they trying to keep him down maybe you
don't want to get up that's all I looked
at it and it wasn't that deep for me
right people act like he was the Lord
and Savior I'm like no government nobody
out here is saving you from your world
because if it works or it doesn't work
you still got to do the work so I'm like
why did everyone get so wrapped up in
that it was kind of crazy but to your
point Whitlock and I agree like this
ain't it right but he agreed in a way
where people like damn dogs yeah kind of
caught up in a little right right right
right but I did my part too
um yo it's crazy so obviously we just
saw everybody get let go at ESPN it was
I mean and they've had a lot of cuts
before yeah Stephen A did a good job of
putting that out on him show like where
were you in this year and all these
people got fired and then this year all
these people got fired yeah but again
your boy Max got let go yeah who is one
of my favorites especially when it comes
to boxing I love when he is is working
the fights
um you know for people who don't know
Max Kellerman used to be a rapper
seriously oh don't even get him started
uh clip out there yeah
um but have you spoken with Max oh yeah
how's he doing and like for you to you
know I mean obviously as somebody who's
kind of doing your own thing now to
witness a line of cuts like that
happening I mean we're talking about
Jeff Van Gundy I know Jalen yeah those
two those are the first two that caught
me off guard
no no I think the max thing we kind of
saw coming yeah exactly Jeff Van Gundy I
was like damn but damn one all right so
Jeff Van Gundy that one caught me the
most off guard but then my second mind
kicked in is like hey bro he'd be going
in on on the NBA for sure is praying I
can understand that do you dive a little
deeper you realize maybe there was a
little uh maybe yeah coffee and tea and
yeah can you let him go or else it's
gonna be tougher in our next negotiation
maybe that
um Jalen Rose caught me off guard but
then I was like yeah him and Max kind of
in the same boat they start chipping
away at what your what your products are
your entities so no more him Jalen and
Jacoby then this happens right because
the Jacoby Jalen show got cut first he
got cut first max no first take for a
while this just in which felt like a
filler show like all right you're not
here here you go yeah but I don't think
Max leaves our show leaves LA to do this
just in and people don't think like this
but you get that in consolation but this
is why I left ESPN in less forced Nation
it's one thing to be getting paid and
Max was getting paid but he got paid to
do first take and now here they go with
a plan B like okay you don't Steve
Steven they don't want you on first take
anymore we got this for you right yeah
but that ain't for you that's just
something to kind of fill the time it's
something for us to to justify us paying
you still exactly yeah and so there's a
huge difference between them paying you
and them supporting you right now I feel
that Sports Nation with all the rotating
hosts and co-hosts and I was like they
paying me but they don't I don't see
foresight I don't see Runway I don't see
where they're all invested in the next
five years of the show and it was tough
to call their Bluff because every time
you say that they're like oh of course
we are of course you are right and then
I said all right I'ma leave and as soon
as I left they cancel that show proven
my point I was on thin ice the show was
on thin ice one day they'll just wake up
and be like ah Sports Nation it was
novel back then 10 years ago now
everyone has a touch screen yeah
everyone interacts with the fans and
social media so I was like uh I got
ahead of that one I felt the same for
Max I was thinking like damn this ain't
gonna last this just in even though it
wasn't a bad show it just wasn't the
show he would have left L.A to go and do
that right so saw that coming man and
you know he has a little time on he has
time to work with in terms of still
getting paid by ESPN develop what's next
he's certainly in the running for
Undisputed depending on how they really
do that but they're talking about their
rotating partnership what they're doing
at ESPN they might do at FS1 yeah which
makes sense which they actually got from
skip so I want to clarify everybody
thinks Stephen A started this back in
the day that's what skip used to do
that's what skip used to do people don't
remember that cold pizza was always like
Woody page or Stephen A or the twin the
stoop stoop twins I remember them I I
know you're talking about uh God I
forget and they're gonna kill Monty
Jones was on a lot of people
come on there yeah so it was a thing
before Stephen A revamped it and now
skip may go back to it